MIDDLE OF THE ICE AND SPEND
SHOT RIGHT ON!
CHIPS IT INTO THE COLUMBUS
REINFORCEMENT.IN AFTER IT.
SANFORD GETS TO THAT SECOND BACT
POINT.
BLUE JACKETS CONTROL.
GAVRIKOV FOR
ON THE KILL FOR THE FIRSTS BLUE
JACKETS.
HERE COMES CONNOR
SHORTHANDED!
SCORES! AND HE'S THE
BENEFICIARY.
HE'S IN T IN AT THE LINE BY
BOQVIST.
LE
LOOK AT HOW MUCH TIME HE HAS
UP HIGH.
DOESN'T WIND UP WITH THE CHASINO
C.
GAVRIKOV.
GIVEAWAY FROM LOBEGAN
STANLEY
COACH OF THE LOS ANGELES THOUGHS
OFF THE GLOVE.
SCORES!
evin: I BELIEVE THAT PUTS
HIM IN THE TOPY SCHEIFELE.
PIONK ON THE LOOSE PUCK.
AND HE COULD GET.
TIED UP ALONG THE BOARDS WITH
SHOT FROM THE LINE.
BLOCKED BY STASTNEY.H FROM
MERZLIKINS.
POTENTIAL SHOT FROM SCHEIFELE
AND TH
ASSIST IN THE OPENING PERIOD.
PLAYED AROUND THE BOARDS.
SVECHNIKOV FOROLUMBUS NET.
NYQUIST WILL START RIGHT BAC
>> Kevin: THAT'S GARBAGE.
>> Dennis: ATIALLY.
DANGEROUS HIT FROM BEHIND ON TIE
CAREER HIGH F TEN.
>> Kevin: THEY'LL GO WITH THE
THREE FORWARD ATT ON
MERZLIKINS.